thanks for joining us America Jewell is
with us in Sarasota Florida
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Jule
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up okay my husband are not
on the same page and so I'm wondering if
I should start investing a little now a
little now what do you mean yeah start
doing some investing in science 53 years
old and I have no retirement at all okay
what it's very difficult to have a great
marriage when you don't work together
own money and it's very difficult to win
on money when you don't work together on
money yes so where are you not on the
same page and why well I've been trying
for years to get him on a budget and it
just won't happen
couple years I've got a line you know
one sort of one or two months and then
all the sudden it just stops or I find
out that he's not telling me everything
so pretty much I try to pace get off but
of course every time I get it paid off
it seems like comes right back on so I
am kind of banging my head against a
wall you're gonna continue to there's
not a fixed for that except a marriage
fixed you guys are gonna have to get on
the same page and we're cuz you can't
fill up the hole as fast as he can dig
it out and so it's just it's just it's
imperative that the two of you get to
where you have trust and respect for him
because he is trustworthy and respect
worthy right now he's in his mind he's
just kind of doing whatever he wants to
do in your mind he's lying and broken a
contract when he when he violates the
budget that you agreed to but he hadn't
heard loud and clear that this is signed
in blood and right so we need to sit
down and do a game plan and say honey
we've got we're 53 were broke we
I've got to do something I can't stand
this it's driving me nuts and you
wandering off after three months of
being on the budget and going back in
debt again is driving me nuts this is no
longer okay Dave I've tried everything
and it's just not going to happen so I'm
kind of well and I think I need to go
see a marriage counselor because I can
tell you darling I mean I've been doing
this for 30 years I have never seen a
single person when financially when
their spouse is going the other
direction they just don't because it's
easier for him to get into debt than it
is for you to get out it's easier for
you to get into debt than it is for him
to get you out if it was the other way
around and it going into debt in America
today I mean you don't even have to have
two brain cells to rub together
you barely sign your name make your
little X and you can be in you can be in
$10,000 in debt but in 20 minutes just
walk through the mall
I mean it's nuts and so until there's a
sense of destiny in a sense of control
and a sense of vision for your finances
you guys are going to struggle and so
and I got to tell you you're either
gonna kind of bump along like this and
you might bump along like this and stay
this way but my experience is eventually
you do erupt and you get so disgusted
and disillusioned and you've lost all
respect for him and it starts to it
starts to tear every part of the
marriage apart after a while
and so I just I I can't give your
finances hope until I give your marriage
hope so I'm gonna send you not to
Financial Peace University but instead
to a marriage counselor